for the sixth day of Christmas we've
gone with carbon element number six and
a particular sort of coal called
anthracite which is almost pure carbon
this is a sample of anthracite that was
sent to me by a YouTube fan called David
Harris I think in Pennsylvania
anthracite is really looks rather
beautiful it looks almost like bits of
metal it's very light and it's almost
pure carbon
I think after Christmas we're gonna get
Neil to burn some of this but David also
sent me some ash that is left over from
the burning some of it went into the
bottle I put it into a bottle but one
piece was just too big and what's
interesting about this ash which I think
was burnt in the furnace is that it's
very light I think these are just bits
of minerals which were included in the
ant lumps of anthracite and they didn't
remove properly according to David that
anthracite burns with almost a colorless
flame so again that's something which we
can test in a future video and although
it's coal it's not at all dirty I can
rub it on my hand and you can see none
of it comes off so for the 6th day of
Christmas element carbon in anthracite a
glowing guitar paper for drink
three chemical badges two periodic table
bed covers one piece of tartaric acid
from a Swiss wine barrel and let's see
what's number seven
pressure and the gas we get out into our
pipe so this is really for safety
because the pressure inside the cylinder
is a lot higher than the pressure that
we require now reaction inside a balloon
so this is my present for the first day
of Christmas